Around 80% of all Asians have an allele of ADH that increases the activity 40
to a 100 times that above normal. And about 50% of all Asians have an allele of
ALDH2 that slows its activity significantly. And this
all results in an accumulation of the toxic
product, acetaldehyde and prevalence of the alcohol flush
reaction in Asian populations. The increase in acetaldehyde
base side effects is so prevalent that it makes
the drinking of alcohol far less enjoyable than many
other populations find it to be. As a result
alcoholism rates are actually much lower in Asian populations
where we have a high prevalence of the alcohol
flush reactions. Based on this mechanism of action, a
drug's been developed called Disulfiram. That is used to
treat alcoholism, by inducing the negative side effects of drinking.
Namely, the sickness reaction that happens in alcohol flush. So
if Disulfiram inhibits one of these proteins. Do you think it's
most like to inhibit ADH or ALDH2? Pick one of
those answers and tell me why in the text box here.